a Massachusetts woman allegedly
kidnapped and missing for three days is
safe at home this morning after a
high-tech search by police 23 year-old
Olivia Ambrose was found yesterday she
disappeared Saturday night after leaving
a bar in Boston with a suspect that
suspect has now been identified as
Victor Pena he was arrested and charged
with kidnapping he is expected in court
later today
Nikki batise is in the charleston
neighborhood of Boston with how this
search unfolded Nikki this is such great
news good morning to you unbelievable
news Gail good morning Olivia Ambrose
was found in an apartment at this
housing complex she was then taken to a
hospital where she appeared to be in
good physical condition just hours after
she was found police were here last
night gathering evidence and looking for
a motive it's been a long night and day
but well worth it
Boston Police Commissioner William gross
says officers had no need to force their
way into the apartment where they found
Olivia Ambrose the suspect Victor Pena
opened his door for them she was
observed standing inside of the
apartment near the suspect we eventually
separated them a lengthy digital trail
including these surveillance images of
the suspect helped crack the case
Ambrose was last seen just after 11 p.m.
Saturday leaving a bar called
Hennessey's about 40 minutes later
police say security cameras captured
Pena and another man leading Ambrose to
a nearby subway station it's obvious
from the video surveillance that she did
not go along willingly just after
midnight Pena and Ambrose were spotted
leaving a different subway station her
cell phone pinged a few minutes later
near the apartment where she was
eventually found it's about a mile from
the bar former Boston Police
Commissioner Ed Davis there are cameras
on buses cameras on trains in all of
those areas are exploited by police when
something happens his motive is still
unknown but according to the Boston
Globe Transit Police have twice kicked
the 38 year-old out of the subway for
menacing women at least one of Pena's
neighbor says she had an uneasy
encounter with him last year he was
following me
[ __ ] he was in the summertime police
say they don't know if Pina was also at
the bar Saturday they didn't find any
weapons in his home and don't know if he
threatened Ambrose she was reported
missing by her family Sunday her twin
sister Frannie said the 23 year old was
not the kind of person to just disappear
the Ambrose family you never gave up and
the people of Boston never gave up
police are looking to question that
second man seen in the security cameras
they're also determining whether pana
should face additional charges and Nora
the Ambrose family released a statement
last night thanking police and this
community for their support oh my
goodness I'm so happy they found her
Nikki thank you so much